now you might have seen this insane
viral video all aboard the toxic gossip
train yes YouTuber Colleen Bollinger
issued a non-apology apology video via
song using a ukulele now that's bad
enough but it looks like she's decided
to register that song with CD Baby and
Apple iTunes for the purposes of
copyright striking people that are using
this viral video against her while you
dramatize your lies and monetize their
demise now two things are important here
number one the song was already
copyrighted when she put out the video
It Happened automatically she didn't
have to register it but obviously
registering it allows her to go through
this process and use the copyright
system additionally it still qualifies
as fair use the commentary that's coming
in excoriating her it's totally fair use
and if someone takes her to court she's
going to lose
surviving
which reminds me if you need a great
lawyer my firm the eagle team can take
care of it the link for that is down in
the comments